you're gonna hear from retailer sluggy
calling a Stanford on hearing matching
market sufficient not for the invitation
yes I'm going to talk about congestion
in marketplaces but not using prices
really in matching markets so the idea
is that there's lots of marketplaces
that need matching some of them are more
centralized some of more decentralized
platforms that today that need a lot of
matching activity and we'll try to
understand how can we reach good
outcomes using signals and match
recommendations so this is joint work
with mark Braverman yashka Nuria and
thing she so the and we're going to
adopt a very classic setting to think
about how to reach an equilibrium
outcome this is going to be a basically
a static setting but what we're going to
do is measure the used communication in
order to be just the equilibrium outcome
so we're going to adopt a two sided
matching market by Gale and Shapley so
there's going to be two sides one is
with workers one was with firms and
participants agents and films have
strict preferences over agents potential
partners from the other side of the mic
okay so there's no transfers here and in
this model they also introduced the
concept of stability so matching between
agents and firms is stable if no firm
and worker prefer to match to each other
over their current partners and why
stability is interesting it's it's can
be considered as an equilibrium outcome
in these kind of markets it's been used
a lot in centralized kind of
marketplaces in many school choice
systems in the national residency
matching program in decentralized
markets it's been used to predict
outcomes and analyze welfare in general
you if you're running a platform maybe
you don't exactly get stability but you
want to achieve something that at least
is close in order that maybe your
participant won't go and find try to
match matches somewhere else
okay so just a few examples for why is
there congestion you need to communicate
with your partners in order to express
your preferences and that's what and
these things can take time so for
example evidence from online labor
platforms that 10% of job applications
receiver is only only 10% receiver
response well there's about 50% of job
openings and job openings remaining
vacant so decentralize markets it just
takes time to tell someone I like you to
invite someone to apply and so forth so
it might take too much time to find the
equilibrium in centralized markets we
see in school choice system people
actually not submitting their entire
preferences it takes might even time to
learn about your own preferences or
international residency matching market
there's 20,000 graduate doctors every
year and you definitely don't rank all
of them you need to invite them for an
interview and typically you see people
are ranking like 15 those that they
interviewed so in and in fact there is a
puzzle there's negative results about
finding a stable matching so in order to
find - to aggregate all the information
agent needs to or the amount of
information agent needs to learn and
communicate to find a stable matching
actually in the worst case grows
linearly with the market size so this is
a resolved first by Cigala in a pretty
beautiful paper in jet and then there's
the strengthening of this result to
randomize kind of protocols so this is
the worst case result that you need a
lot of communication in order to find a
stable matching so if it's so that means
you need to communicate whether a
significant part of the market in order
to eventually find a stable match so
what we want to do in this paper is
actually relax the worst case kind of
assumption and give impose some
assumption on preferences as weak as
possible but still find a stable
matching with not too much communication
and or to help the market using maybe
match recommendations or informative
signals to to reach them of course if
everything is known all the preferences
are known there's no need for
communication at all I can
to implement the stable matching but we
want weak preferences as possible to
reach a stable matching with low
communication and hopefully well through
those algorithms or those protocols that
are we going to reach there will give
some good insights who should correspond
with who in order to to better to get
there and what one type of insight is
first of all you don't want two people
to communicate with each other if
there's no chance really too much
another one is that agents should reach
out to easy to get partners and hope
that better partners kind of reach out
to them okay so I'll present the model
the assumptions on the on the
preferences but before this what are we
actually measuring and I'll discuss the
how we get to our stable matching in
these kind of models so the primitives
we have a set of workers we have a set
of firms there's going to be some state
of the world that incorporates the
distribution over preferences okay so
agents there's going to know something
about the state of the world or be
pretty precise on what they know and
what they don't one thing we're gonna
assume is the proof agents actually
don't know really their preferences but
they have some Oracle that answers to
them for any subset of workers as who is
their favorite agent among this set so
you can easily recover a list of of
who's your first choice with your second
choice and so forth over an agent's by
making inquiries to this Oracle
so Omega incorporates the distribution
and there's some distribution that's the
some distribution over preferences and
I'll tell you exactly in a couple of
slides what exactly they know and what
they don't so right now it's very
abstract yes now so I just might not
even know their preferences they need to
recover and that would be important to
measure how much communication or
learning is happening until we reach the
outcome agents are going to communicate
sending message to each other or to a
platform and there's going to be some
communication protocols that is going to
decide who is the next agent that is
going to send the message based on the
history of messages and they're going to
certain what type of message and the
manner the agent is going to send the
message betters based also on its
private information what we're going to
measure is really how many calls are we
doing to this Oracle and how much bits
of information are sent throughout the
protocol until we find a stable matching
so and we're going to encode every
message with bits zero one bit so if you
want us if there's an agent if each
agent can be represented by log n bits
yes you can think about this is
centralized yes that's that's that's
gonna be the centralized history say now
you talk yes that will count yes but the
the decision for let that person talk
that does not count against the
communication cost so it's not going to
cost against I shouldn't account because
there's coordination in essence so it
doesn't matter if it's oh it's just
another point okay you talk now it just
adds another algorithmic right but I
just feel like this this pulling
information and sending back into this
kind of a choice of who gets to talk
that is a that is a lot of Education
as opposed to decentralized way like you
know everybody decides whether they want
to talk we don't count this but I don't
think it affects much let's take this
offline so here's a one type of protocol
that is a variation of the deferred
acceptance algorithm also introduced by
Gale and Shapley that finds a stable
matching here's the this variation at
any point in time there's you look at
who are those unmatched workers and you
pick one of them and he's going to apply
to his favorite film that he hasn't
applied so far okay that film let's call
it J is going to look at his all his
proposals so far or he's going to keep
the best proposal so fun compare the new
application I to this tentative proposal
and reject the one that he likes less
and keep the one he likes more and that
keeps on continuing you can go on to the
next and worker that is unmatched until
this process ends and you find a stable
matching so this is one type of protocol
that as a consequence from the results
by cigarette I'll then it's going to
take a long time to find a stable energy
yes but maybe you can do something
smarter than this okay so this is the
this formula this puzzle by by these
papers in a two sided market with n
agents there exist distribution of
preferences that no protocol will
actually find something that in that is
growing sub linearly in the number of
agents what we want to ask is what is
needed in typical markets so we want to
make some assumptions over preferences
okay so there's a lot of literature on
structure of stable matching in large
markets and also on congestion there's a
growing literature but for interest of
time I'll continual decided to put it up
in case when someone wants to look at
the video later there's a lot of this is
I think very interesting stuff
developing okay so here's some
assumptions on our preferences first of
all for workers we make no assumptions
over their preferences they have
arbitrary preferences over favor for
films they they their preferences are
gonna come from a Latin utility model
where the utility for film J over worker
I has the following structure it's
composed first from some public or
systematic score could that could depend
both on J and I and this is known to I
and J it can also may be known to a
platform that can estimate it think
about this component as I look at your
CV and you know that the job description
and so forth and we know there there's
some fit there's also either syncretic
score or a private score that is drawn
from some distribution independently for
each I and J and it's unknown to
everyone the way that you're going to
figure out who you like first and second
is using this Oracle distribution
depends on the front yes so we need some
we need some assumptions on these
components because for if we don't have
if this is not sufficiently informative
then we can plug the AJ is into the
previous negative results okay so those
utilities induce rankings over workers
and then we can get anything we want so
this has to be important and we make the
following assumptions first of all that
the distribution from which is strong
has a bounded hazard rate so it is
heavy-tailed distribution that means
that after looking at sufficiently many
workers there's someone I really like
according to this score the second
assumption is that if you look at the
film jail look at who he likes the most
based on the public score and who he
likes the less according to public the
public score this range is bounded by
some poly logarithmic so if we can't
have it unrestricted again because it
will we'll go back to the negative
results but this captures a lot of you
can capture with this a lot of vertical
differentiation so for example you can
if this is large enough for example even
login you can find fitness course such
that you have a poly logarithmic number
of tears that everybody agrees on but
you cannot have n tears but you have you
can that everybody prefers someone from
a higher to an orator as long as there's
not too many tips any questions about
the assumptions so so again this is not
known to anyone this is known to inj so
there's two types of so I'm going to
present now in the next slide the
protocol that helps you reach stable
matching quickly hopefully quickly so
there's going to be two types of signals
throughout the protocols one is the
preference signals and think about them
as a preference singer like somehow I
know that I really like you based on
their private score that I'm going to
figure out and I'm going to send your
invitation to apply to this job okay
another type of signal is a choir
qualification requirement signal and
here we're going to actually broadcast
it for free we're not going to charge
any cost for that so what is this every
film Jay is going to have some
qualification requirements ZJ which
tells workers you cannot apply if your
if your public score is not at least
this qualification requirement or if you
got an invitation for us that's what's
going to happen so the whole idea behind
the protocol will be to run something
like the deferred acceptance algorithm
but to skip a lot of application that
didn't have a chance anyway to be
accepted so here's how the protocol
works every film is going to start with
a qualification requirement which equals
to the public score of the of the worker
they like the least okay and slowly
throughout the algorithm this
qualification requirement is going to
going to be tougher and tougher okay so
what if every firm is going to do before
we run anything that has to do with the
further acceptance there's kind of a
first round they're going to been every
film is gonna be in workers based on
only the public scores which they know
into bins of size one so there's going
to be up to four a logarithmic number of
and they're going to figure out who are
the workers they like the loadmasters
about square root and workers they lack
the most in each bin using the queries
and send them invitation signals tell
them you are welcome to apply and now
yes every every call to every call to a
truth yes so this is not we're not
talking about that that's I think an
interesting complimentary question
here's every call to the query so the
Oracle is just one unit so now we're
going to run a sequential version that I
presented of the worker proposing
deferred acceptance every time there's
going to be just one worker that
proposes and a work is only going to
propose the Fizi publicly qualified or
he got an invitation signal and
otherwise he skipped that application
and go to the next one on his list okay
so he proposes to the most favorite one
as long that he hasn't proposed to as
long as these conditions hold otherwise
he skips it and films are going to
update the qualification requirement
over time added once if there's enough
people who are publicly qualified that
the applied they're going to increase
their qualification requirement by one
each time so this protocol what it does
is suppresses all these applications
that have didn't have any chance anyway
to be accepted and it will find a stable
matching with respect to the true
preferences with high probability so
that's the that's the the first tier and
we find a stable matching with high
probability but also the amount of
communication is going to be growing at
square root order for agent okay instead
of the linear one and the idea is that
basically if what we all you want to
show is that when you skip a proposal
you don't have a chance to get accepted
anyway and you didn't have a chance
because if the price if the you
not publicly qualified and this the
pheromone increases the qualification
requirement is there a lot of publicly
qualified people who applied and that's
why it's going to work yes just the
market grows large that the the formal
theory the market grows large with high
probability for really converging to one
you will find a stable matching with
respect to the true presence and also
this result is tight in the sense that
even if both sides have separable kind
of preferences you really need this
amount of communication per agent
there's also nice incentive properties
I'll skip that one limitation of the of
this of this protocol is that it's
sequence every time there is just one
application it's not happening at the
same time another is that all these
public messages which are from the
qualification requirements which we
broadcast so I want to address to give
you just one to impose a little bit more
structure on preferences and hopefully
get a rid of both the sequential a
secret reality and also these broadcast
messages so special case of kind of
several preferences is the following
suppose workers and films are we can we
can put there there's some kind of a
steer structure for each side and
everybody agrees on the tier structure
so that means that every film likes
workers from a higher tier to a lower
tier but within a tier the preferences
are drawn uniformly at random for each
agent independently and you can have any
number of tiers okay so the target here
what is the target here the target here
is defined to be the the lowest the
highest tier basically that the worker
can guarantee at least as good worker
from our firm from that tier so this for
example the second
here's the target here for the top tier
workers and for the top tier field the
first tier of workers is their target
area okay so basically what's going to
happen is going to be communication
between agents to their target Tier one
special case is when both sides have is
one tier when both sides have just
uniform random preferences and let's
suppose there's fewer firms than workers
and by a result we had before with Josh
canola and Jacob lush know we know that
every firm on the on the short side is
going to be matched with high
probability in a stable matching to one
of their top preferences specifically
log Square and preferences what does
this mean this means that you can find a
stable matching with very low
communication films will say first to
the workers that are really on the top
of the list we like you invites invite
them to apply and then we're going to
run workers proposing the third
acceptance or calculate the stable
matching that is is that we take the
Preferences that are just induced from
those signals from the first round we
don't need to consider any other worker
doesn't need to consider any other any
film that didn't signal because in a
stable matching they will just not match
to them so in one round you signal in
another wound you just calculate the
stable matching and it will be stable
with respect to the true preferences you
can easily extend this to when you have
large a finite number of large tiers for
example here there's let's say two tiers
or films one tier of workers so the
signals in the first round are going to
work as follows those films are going to
signal workers that they like under that
they really like based on their
idiosyncratic no here you don't actually
always so you can figure out by calling
again the Oracle who are your top
workers that you like you're going to
signal them invite them to apply and
workers are going to at the same time
we're going to signal the films on the
bottom tier also invite them to reply
send them a preference
and the reason that they're doing this
is that they don't know who's going to
match to those top films some of them
are just going to left be left out so
just in case there are inviting them to
apply so this is all happening at once
now you look at all the Preferences
induced by the signals either that you
sent or received and you find a stable
matching with respect to those
preferences okay and that's going to be
of also work and generally you can have
any number of tiers so you can have a
two round protocol that in the first
round everybody's got going to send
signals to their target ear
not too many signals and then agents are
going to rank partners based on their
signals days either sent or received and
we're finally going to find a stable
matching based on those preferences and
that's going to find the stable matching
with high probability with low very low
communication so we get rid of the
sequentiality and we get rid of the
broadcast cannibals
okay just a little bit about how many
signals do we really need to send here's
a little bit of intuition so on the on
the left side there's a top tier with 50
workers 5000 tier with 50 also 50
workers so what's going to happen here
everybody is sending signals to their
target here so they're not going to send
signals to those 50 those guys are going
to send two to this tier here so some of
these people will be matched to workers
some of those friends will be matched to
workers here but those guys they don't
know they can't just take anyone here
some of them are going to go to better
tiers so we're defining some notion of
competitiveness of an agent so
competitiveness of an agent here is
going to be higher if more of this is
going to more of these firms are left
for them less of them they of they have
to compete more so the number of signals
that you're going to send is going to be
inversely proportional to the
competitiveness to your competitiveness
okay so the fewer that are left here the
more you need to send signals of course
if there's very few people left and you
don't need to send someone just under
one example maybe how to think about
this suppose you have universally ranked
films the top theorem second everybody
agrees on this and here's there's the
preferences of workers is completely
uniform at random we know that this film
can just choose who they want to match
to but people here on the bottom are
going to experience a lot of
communication but on average we can find
something that is this has logarithmic
communication per agent but these guys
will have a lot so corollary from this
is that in a to run protocol some agents
will have a lot of communications
sometimes but but not too many of them
it's interesting maybe to find a stable
matching with every round there's not
too much communication and but there's
not too many rounds okay so let me
summarize so first of all I think this
work is maybe helping to to think a
little bit about those negative
resultant and justify maybe stability as
a solution concept giving those large
communication results so maybe explains
why we can believe in stability and but
also I think gives some perspective
guidelines for matching platforms so one
thing you want to do is really estimate
the chances for matches to really a core
and for example have agents reach down
to two partners to easier to get
partners and hope to get be reached out
from better partners and we see some
some kind of this behavior in different
kind of lab experiments
so overall we the contribution we give
some assumptions on preferences that we
could hopefully weak assumptions that
hopefully makes sense in some context
and that we find the stable marching
with low customer camera of
communication but also these protocols
give a lot of insight of what kind of
signals and recommendation we can do in
order to help the market reach a stable
outcome sqrt n per agent in in the
general surprised that didn't I think we
need to think more about what to do in
the few B one related to your talk
yesterday how do we want would not leave
those guys out and maybe involved in yes
we don't have answers to that
don't say what it felt right so in
practice I don't think stabilities even
as we're very we don't have always
stability because people it's also
really costly to to communicate with
someone so we get approximate the billet
but for matera just from a mathematical
point of view it's just I don't know
what's happening matches what happens in
practice those after markets yes
they're second rounds of the further
acceptance with just random matching
people just communicate somehow what
usually happens
my intuition is that as n grows large
the noise and estimation of my own
preferences is such that you know strict
preferences my preferences are no longer
strict you know there are ties and I
imagine this same thing would be true
for firms right I'm willing to hire so
my intuition is that communication will
drop if there's more in differences but
we didn't study this but just because
there's more options and to match with
[Music]
[Applause]